this show is gross
also zombies are this ravenous even for
roadkill how do any new zombies ever
come back to life when the existing zoms
picked the bones of any kill clean
before the person even has a chance to
turn also also do zombies get full does
the digestive system even work or does
it just keep piling in until their
stomach pops what about zombies that are
missing a stomach does the meat fester
in their body
I'm just saying of all the monsters
zombies make the least sense when you
really sink your teeth into them I'm
also calling both zombies still having
so much clothing on look at this group
baby they've all got shoes on this guy
has a lab coat that somehow still on and
this one still in a bathrobe and what is
this a suspender how is he still wearing
it suspenders so we supposed to believe
the helicopter led them here because
that helicopter was not headed to
Herschel's phone and you can argue they
just started wandering this way and
here's where they ended up all you want
but then why even show the helicopter in
the first place why would all these
[ __ ] even follow a helicopter
in the first place check hogs helicopter
stubbornly refuses to check out properly
also I like to think the Shah is just
the status of Walking Dead viewers who
had to numb their brains for a season of
people hanging out on a farm and talking
about my new ship also also welcome to
the worst no trespassing sign in the
history of trespassing signs what does
this even mean is it welcoming
trespassers because they have control of
their own ass and why is there no
apostrophe in it's shouldn't that mean
it's possessive like your ass that
belongs to it so if we trespass it's
your ass does that mean we're invading
your ass after it's been taken by it the
sign is like an exponential version of
the pronoun game and I hate exponential
versions of things especially pronouns
this zombie is practicing the
lesser-known zombie terror of not
letting your cardigan fall off your arm
thing is Shane and Randall's tractor
right on top of each other Sherlock
Dixon in the case the two [ __ ]
footprints and wasn't Shane you know
that used to be even in death Shane
causes boring tedious scenes to occur on
this show here Rick and quarrel have a
good 50-yard lead on the weight --fill
debt but somehow in just a few seconds
that dead have fully caught up despite
plotting along at the usual pace I just
don't buy it I mean the word walking is
right there in the title the truth is
zombies are boring and I'm pretty sure
every action scene here involved in the
ms2 he blew up country you pick up the
singer - like ringworm z : gastric flu
if you want has that been an option this
whole time cuz this farm is felt like a
prison all season I'm sure the next
season will be different the writers
will completely change it up and do
something totally on prison like Oh
dropping lighter stays lit and
immediately catches everything on fire
when it hits the ground because gasoline
is magic fire juice cliche it doesn't
matter Glenn the good guys on this show
somehow hit 80% head shots from any
distance despite being on moving
vehicles Walking Dead good guys are the
exact opposite of stormtroopers the last
two minutes of this episode have been
gunshots and characters trying to figure
out who started the fire and it's even
more boring than it sounds what exactly
was the plan here surely he heard Rick
and Carl jump down why didn't he
continue driving after that why is the
scene despite the entire compound being
overrun by the dead there are just six
Abhi's behind the Winnebago for Rick and
quarrel to deal with episode is composed
of 73 percent shooting of firearms 56
percent zombie sauntering and 31 percent
characters yelling each other's names
also is this an actual episode of the
show or just an ad for zombie paintball
hayride attractions because I can't tell
the difference because all this ammo
coming from it been on a farm for what
seems like four years here by shopping
would be severely limited and probably
picked clean at this point Hershel will
now take over a dozen uninterrupted
shots with his shotgun and while there
might be a few shotguns out there
designed to hold this many shells with s
trigger-happy as this crew is right now
I think it's safe to say we should be
seeing a lot more reloading than the
almost zero we've seen so far
how does area not realize there are
zombies behind her
sure Andrea's probably lunch meat by now
but they could have at least spun around
and drove over by her to check the
characters give up quicker on each other
than the cast of the mist that doesn't
seem like gun at all usually strikes me
as someone who's willing to sacrifice to
save others I can't think of anyone
who's not willing to go to bat for
where's Laurie did you see Morey forget
Laurie I'm just amazed he can even still
hear you after you shot that gun right
by his ear they just keep coming it's
like a plague they're everywhere yeah I
thought that was already understood my
show do you think you're on
okay fine there are times when the show
is downright cinematic and this shot of
the barn burning down and is gorgeous
and even a bit cathartic
take your sin back and let's move on
yeah yeah I love you I should have said
a long time when he's been sure for a
long time
Glenda's right it's silly that he hasn't
told her this yet especially when we all
knew it was destined to happen right off
the bat is there a good reason to drive
while holding the shotgun there has to
be somewhere else to put it for easy
access that doesn't have the risk of
Glenn blowing his head off while taking
a sharp left Christ promised a
resurrection of the Dead I just thought
he had something a little different in
mind so now we're blaming Jesus for the
show's downfall maybe you should have
started at not firing Frank Darabont and
then moved on from there let me damn
minds tdawg would be excellent at TV
sins what did you find everyone these
guys tail that zigzagging all over the
road really had to be Asian driving like
that you're what's a little racism
between friends MoMA is meant to dodge a
valid question how did all of you just
happened to show up for this family
reunion at the exact same time oh I'm so
glad they cut away from actual action to
show Rick dealing with a truck running
out of gas that's way more interesting
look around
okay there's Walker's I don't see any at
all around them I'm beginning to think
Glenn may be blind as a what's the
phrase again oh yeah a bat we're all
infected and you never said anything
made a difference yes it would have had
a character as smart as you're supposed
to be you would know that not having
this information could directly lead to
people putting themselves in unsafe
situations and the only reason you
didn't tell the others is for bull
stretch the TV tension reasons I chose
Shane no one will be seated during the
Rick stares into the distance and
monologues about struggling with the
morality of a decision as the camera
zooms in on him for a full three minutes
portion of the episode stay you sex
Mashona also yeah it's the introduction
of a fan favorite from the comics glad
this will be an awesome adaptation of a
character and they will never take away
what makes her special and she will
always be interesting so happy about
that also also we want to introduce the
character and the season finale but
haven't cast the role yet so we cover
the face cliche we get one thing
straight this isn't a democracy anymore
Rick's final speech is impacting people
exactly the way you would think except
for Glenn who doesn't even seem to bat
an eye what what did I say
Slayer killjoy double kill triple kill
overkill X term until tacular Gilley's
pill tricycle Amin Jarrah kill baccala
killed test roof and Killian air killing
friends running riot rampage perfection
is more crazy badass apocalyptic savage
still smoking star maybe recon standing
by magic waiting for your accountability
standing by rather than miss already
watching sentry gun ready to deformed
airstrike standing by
ready for deployment emergency airdrop
there's no ready for deployment I'm
really gonna be sorry to see the farmers
go Carl no that's my boy gonna have to
trust if he find him he's gonna need his
mother we've got to go get me back my
son look at me look at me
undercut the gnome we've all been
through hell and worse but at least we
found each other you don't turn your
back on that line
there's henchmen I deserve better people
never think how things affect the family
of a henchman don't panic
[Music]